nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
nous allons parler aujourd'hui d'une des
drogues les plus dangereuses au monde
qu'on appelle aussi la cocaïne du pauvre
je veux parler du cristallet nous
prenons la direction de l'Allemagne pour
rejoindre notre correspondante
anne-maillet l'Allemagne car le
cristalmet il fait des ravages il faut
dire que cette drogue est extrêmement
addictive
oui le cristalmet ou mettanthétamine
compte parmi les drogues les plus
addictives au monde le risque de
développer une dépendance notamment
psychologique à ce produit est
extrêmement élevé le taux de rechute est
également très important or cette drogue
se propage un peu partout en Europe et
en Allemagne vous l'avez dit elle fait
déjà des ravages et il n'est pas rare de
rencontrer des consommateurs qui se
battent depuis des années contre cette
addiction alors on va découvrir votre
reportage en Allemagne complété
également par une enquête au Pays-Bas
reportage signé donc anne-maillet et
Alix le bourdon pour France 24
[Musique]
dans le centre de l'Allemagne elle fait
des ravages depuis une décennie
la première fois j'en ai pris avant
d'aller en soirée je traînais avec les
mauvaises personnes et ils m'en ont
proposé on ne se rendait pas compte des
conséquences c'est de la manière dont ça
allait finir et puis ça s'est propagé
comme un fléau dans toute la région
jusque dans les plus petits villages
Félix se bat contre une addiction au
Christel met
cette substance la voici un dérivé de la
méthamphétamine que l'on surnomme aussi
la cocaïne du pauvre
longtemps produite et consommé dans les
pays de l'Est de l'Europe elle se
propage depuis quelques années sur tout
le continent un marché lucratif pour le
crime organisé notamment au Pays-Bas
nous sommes dans la région du Brabant
occidental
Eric de jongue et garde-forestiers il
parcourt ses bois depuis plus de 20 ans
ces dernières années il a développé des
connaissances dans un domaine dont il
ignorait tout la production de drogues
de synthèse
j'ai trouvé ici l'un des plus gros
dépôts sauvages de drogue jamais trouvé
au Pays-Bas
et vous pouvez voir juste derrière moi
d'où la drogue venait
en 2021 il a découvert 18 dépôts
sauvages de déchets liés à cette drogue
particulièrement toxique ici
eric est tombé sur ce que l'on appelle
un puits de drogue vous voyez ici il y a
une trappe et en dessous vous voyez la
boue qui est un déchet de drogue séché
quand on l'a ouvert on a senti une forte
odeur de produits chimiques on a testé
le sol et ici tout est mort il y a des
substances comme le ph-0 ou le ph1 si
vous voulez toucher elle brûle tout
derrière ce décor de campagne tranquille
des dizaines de laboratoires ont été
découverts ces dernières années
sur ces images de la police néerlandaise
une opération de démantèlement à l'été
[Musique]
va au phone arensbergen en quête depuis
plus de 8 ans sur le trafic de drogue
dans cette région située non loin de la
frontière avec l'Allemagne
ce journaliste connaît par cœur c'est
moindre recoin et la criminalité
organisée un gang originaire d'Eindhoven
géré une unité de production dans cette
ferme grâce à un ensemble d'informations
la police est venue ici à observer de la
fumée qui sortait de la cheminée ils
sont revenus quelques heures plus tard
avec un véhicule blindé ils ont fait une
descente et là ils ont trouvé des gens
en train de cuisiner c'est à dire de
fabriquer de la drogue le propriétaire
du terrain a également été arrêté
la région fournit déjà une grande partie
du monde en extasie alors cette zone du
sud des Pays-Bas avec ses réseaux
illégaux bien implantés étaient toutes
désignée pour accueillir la production
et le trafic de crystal meth mais c'est
l'apparition d'un nouvel acteur expert
en la matière qui a changé la donne
il y a quelques années on a constaté une
augmentation du nombre de laboratoires
de cristalmettes il y avait aussi de
plus en plus de Mexicains ils sont venus
enseigner à des producteurs locaux
comment produire cette drogue puisque le
matériel utilisé pour le cristalmet et
le même que celui utilisé pour l'extasy
la recette est différente mais certaines
parties du processus de production sont
identiques c'est pour ça que les
Mexicains sont venus ici parce que les
lignes de production et les contacts
étaient déjà là
en quelques années les Pays-Bas sont
ainsi devenus le principal producteur de
méthamphétamines en Europe une grande
partie de cette production est destinée
à l'Allemagne voisine
dont la région de rhénani du nord-estali
ses officiers des douanes effectuent
chaque jour des contrôles sur la bande
frontalière
[Musique]
nous avons quelques critères et
paramètres précis en tête
quand ces éléments sont réunis on
intervient et on contrôle
mais on est régulièrement confronté à
des profils inattendus ça peut être un
retraité un jeune de 18 ans ou une jeune
femme très sympa
quelques minutes plus tard un véhicule
attire l'attention des douaniers à son
bord un jeune homme en provenance des
Pays-Bas
rien dans cette voiture si ce n'est
quelques grammes de marijuana mais les
douaniers sont désormais très attentifs
à ce nouveau trafic
ça va des drogues douces comme la
marijuana et le haschich à l'héroïne la
méthamphétamine et l’exty mais le trafic
de cristalmed prend de l'ampleur
il y a encore quelques années on ne
connaissait pas ça ici maintenant ça ne
nous surprend plus
tout au long de la frontière Germano
néerlandaise les saisies ont explosé
depuis 2018
celle-ci a été découverte dans le capot
d'une voiture 5 kg de cristalmettes pour
une valeur de 350 000 euros
quand on voit un échantillon on comprend
tout de suite d'où vient le nom cela
ressemble vraiment à des cristaux la
drogue transite par la frontière par les
ports et par la poste en 2021 près de
400 kg de cristalmettes ont été saisies
sur le territoire allemand soit deux
fois plus qu'en 2019 le trafic ses
professionnels
continue d'être produit en République
tchèque
de cristal sont désormais produites au
Pays-Bas
et de là il est envoyé vers toute
l'Europe de l'Est et vers l'est du pays
des régions entières ont déjà succombé à
cette drogue
le long de turinge dans le centre du
pays et particulièrement touché
dans le local de cette association qui
vient en aide aux toxicomane nous
rencontrons Suzy elle vit dans la région
depuis 5 ans c'est ici quel est tombé
dans l'addiction une prise de
cristalmette peut agir jusqu'à 40
Twitter
dedans parce que c'est agréable ça monte
immédiatement au cerveau on est très
conscient éveillé la timidité s'en va et
on perd toute inhibition mais au bout
d'un moment on perd aussi toutes notion
du temps et on fait des fixations
pendant des heures
la métonhétamine compte parmi les
drogues les plus addictives au monde
75% des patients qui essaient de s'en
sortir font une rechute
Claudia plotner a assisté au déferlement
de cette drogue dans la région à une
époque où la substance était encore
fabriquée dans des laboratoires
artisanaux situés dans l'Est de l'Europe
des obstacles au début cette substance
était très bon marché
c'est en tout cas ce que l'on entend
souvent une drogue peut coûteuse et très
puissante
et puis notre région est plutôt rurale
et comme dans d'autres régions comme la
Bavière c'est dans les coins reculés que
cette drogue s'est très vite propagée et
c'est devenu un marché très rentable
dans cette région de 2 millions
d'habitants ont compte déjà 13000
consommateurs réguliers
mais ce n'est pas la première fois que
cette substance fait des ravages dans le
pays
l'ancêtre du cristalmet la pervitine a
été commercialisée en Allemagne dans les
années 1930 200 millions de cachets de
pervitine ont été distribués aux soldats
d'Adolf Hitler pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale on l'appelait alors la pilule
miracle de la Wehrmacht
Martin Walter et psychiatre il est en
charge de l'unité d'addictologie de yéna
selon lui toutes les couches de la
société sont désormais concernées par
cette addiction
ce produit est bien connu depuis
longtemps mais ce que nous voyons en ce
moment et nouveau parce que cette drogue
n'a jamais été aussi accessible
et elle touche des gens qui sont encore
bien intégrés à la société ce sont des
gens qui consomment ce produit à un
niveau qui leur permet de fonctionner
souvent des gens chez qui l'on ne
soupçonne pas une addiction et qui pense
qu'on consomme en petite dose ils
peuvent continuer à vivre une vie
normale
et ça c'est un phénomène assez récent
le Christel met est devenu la drogue
dure numéro 1 dans la région
parmi les patients réguliers de
l'hôpital Félix qui veut garder
l'anonymat il s'apprête à déménager pour
échapper à cette substance qui a tout
détruit autour de lui
on peut se la procurer partout je
connais même des infirmières et des
aides-soignants qui en consomment
ces drogues est pire que tout ce que
l'on a connu dans les années 80 avec
l'héroïne beaucoup de gens meurent j'ai
perdu de nombreux amis des gens bien à
cause de ça
dans le Thuringe on a bien pris la
mesure des conséquences sanitaires de
cette addiction à quelques kilomètres de
là la maternité de l'hôpital de yena il
y a 5 ans le chef du service de
néonatalogie a mis sur pied une
structure d'accueil pour mère toxicomane
en consultation ce jour-là Vanessa elle
a pris sa première dose de crystal meth
à l'âge de 14 ans la dernière il y a un
an
maire d'une petite fille dont la garde
lui a été retirée à cause de sa
consommation elle vient d'accoucher d'un
deuxième enfant une deuxième grossesse
pendant laquelle elle est restée sobre
à 21 ans elle est déterminée à reprendre
sa vie en main
mes journées sont bien mieux organisées
j'ai repris goût à la vie et tout est
plus simple qu'à l'époque où je
consommais
fait preuve de beaucoup de courage parce
que ça n'a pas été facile
mon objectif c'est que mes enfants
soient heureux ils vont bien tous les
deux mais ça ira encore mieux quand nous
serons tous réunis et qu'on pourra
vraiment prendre un nouveau départ
ici tout est fait pour sevrer et
accompagner les jeunes mamans afin
d'éviter les rechutes les dégâts causés
par cette substance sont irréversibles
nous savons que les enfants dont les
mamans ont consommé de la
méthamphétamine pendant la grossesse ne
se développe pas normalement ils sont
trop petits à la naissance le taux
d'enfants-mornée est bien plus important
et souvent il souffre d'un syndrome de
sevrage enfin comme leur tête est trop
petite ils vont souvent développer des
troubles du comportement voire même une
diminution de l'intelligence
dans l'est de l'Allemagne le crystal
meth est considéré comme un enjeu de
santé publique
mais selon l'Observatoire européen des
drogues il se propage dans toute
l'Europe à la recherche de nouveaux
marchés comme le Portugal la Suisse la
Grèce ou la Finlande
les Pays-Bas sont pointés du doigt et
accusés d'être devenu un arco-état
anquick et député chrétienne démocrate
elle a fait de la lutte antidrogue son
cheval de bataille
la production de drogues dans le pays a
complètement basculé vers des drogues
synthétiques et désormais aussi le
cristal met
cela attire des acteurs du monde entier
on a désormais même des Mexicains qui
établissent leur business ici il faut
absolument agir plus durement contre ces
réseaux criminels avec des peines de
prison plus élevées
et plus de contrôle beaucoup plus de
contrôle notamment dans les ports du
pays
en disant les saisies au sein de l'Union
européenne ont augmenté de près de 500 %
de tonnes de cristalmettes ont été
saisis en 2020
et on retrouve notre correspondant en
Allemagne anne-maillet la consommation
de ce produit augmente Anne parce qu'il
y a beaucoup d'argent en jeu c'est
devenu un marché très profitable
oui la consommation augmente en
Allemagne et de plus de manière plus
générale en Europe l'analyse des eaux
usées publiées au mois de mars par le
laboratoire européen des drogues montre
que la consommation a augmenté dans de
nombreuses villes allemandes mais aussi
dans le sud du continent ou encore dans
les pays scandinaves en fait ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est qu'auparavant
cette substance était essentiellement
produite dans des laboratoires
artisanaux situés notamment en
République tchèque il produisait de très
petites quantités et puis le crime
organisé à fleurer le bon filon et c'est
à ce moment là que des quantités de plus
en plus importantes de crise helmet ont
été envoyés vers l'Europe depuis
l'Amérique latine des sites de
fabrication de production de ce produit
ont également vu le jour au Pays-Bas
notamment alors évidemment il est
extrêmement difficile d'évaluer le
chiffre d'affaires de ce trafic mais les
saisies sont de plus en plus importantes
en 2019 par exemple 2500 kg de cristal
meth ont été saisies dans le port de
Rotterdam au Pays-Bas pour une valeur de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
Anne c'est une drogue qui se répand
aussi parce qu'elle s'inscrit d'une
certaine manière dans l'air du temps
oui car il s'agit d'une drogue très bon
marché et surtout très puissante une
toute petite prise de cristalmet peut
permettre à un primo conservateur
consommateur pardon de rester éveillé
deux jours voire trois jours en fait
cette substance agit sur le taux de
dopamine elle donne confiance en soi
alors évidemment à long terme elle
provoque de graves problèmes de santé
des psychoses et dépressions mais au
début c'est ce que nous ont raconté les
consommateurs avec lesquels nous sommes
entretenus elle donne surtout le
sentiment de maîtriser son quotidien
d'assurer au travail d'assurer sa vie de
famille sa vie sociale et en ce sens
c'est ce que souligne de nombreuses
experts c'est vraiment une drogue de la
performance et une drogue qui répond
aussi en quelque sorte aux attentes de
la société
drogue de la performance drogue qui
n'est pas nouvelle elle a été utilisée
par le passé dans des circonstances de
guerre on peut le dire oui cette
substance a effectivement été inventée
dès le 19e siècle au Japon et le
troisième rage on l'a évoqué dans ce
reportage on était très clients les
soldats de la Wehrmacht ont consommé
énormément de méthamphétamines qui
étaient commercialisées à l'époque sous
le nom de pervitine d'ailleurs de
nombreuses historiens estiment que le
blitzkriek la guerre éclair menée par
les soldats d'Adolphe Hitler au début de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale n'aurait pas
été possible sans la méthamphétamine
mais ce que l'on sait un peu moins c'est
que la société civile en a consommé
également énormément l'industrie
pharmaceutique et en vanter les mérites
auprès des femmes au foyer on pouvait
même se la procurer sous forme de
praline au chocolat et ce n'est
finalement que dans les années
1980 donc très tard que ce produit a été
définitivement retiré du marché officiel
et pour être ensuite évidemment produit
de manière illégale un maillet
correspondante de France 24 en Allemagne
merci Anne c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]